okay wait what are we doing today what
are you doing oh wow this is gonna be
hard
my relationship with negative self-talk
is probably one of my strongest
relationships that's not weird to say
negative self-talk it feels true you are
stupid you are like ugly you're bad
you're a bad friend why am I putting
myself out there people don't care
you're not good enough you're too fat
you're you're not funny
are you sure should you really be doing
that I hate myself oh that one happens a
lot hate myself and no one wants to be
around you oh okay okay let me go write
this cuz but I'm not gonna cry not yet
I've got it we're gonna have to read
this out loud in here great okay cool
great I'm gonna go write hey you
thank you for being the person you are
thank you for getting out of bed today
it's so hard to simply get out of bed
sometimes but at least you did that
today thank you for healing and telling
me how you feel even though I forgot to
listen for a while thank you for always
trusting me and that feeling in your
chest thank you for all of your flaws
every scar every roll on your tummy
thank you for still having faith in
humanity despite how cold the world
would be for enduring workouts you
didn't need I'm sorry for those and for
hating you for so long
making thirteen year old you feel like
the coolest person on the planet I don't
think I've been fair with you I'm sorry
I was embarrassed by you I'm sorry for
not giving
you a break I forgive you for rejecting
me for years remember you are wonderful
and powerful I know we're nowhere near
where we want to be on this journey but
thank you for making it majority one
help arrived sorry I hurt and resented
you thank you for feeling it all I will
be nicer we both deserve to feel good to
you know deep down you are awesome thank
you I love you heart me you've worked
hard to get to where you are you belong
here
you're right where you you're supposed
to be you were enough don't ever forget
that it feels like a it's a like an
apology letter to someone that I've
heard so much I feel bad for having been
so so mean and critical for so long and
it feels nice to just sort of stop and
say thanks sometimes it's hard to think
about all the stuff you've done good
like what you say out loud matters and I
know that you are exactly where you're
supposed to be you are good enough you
deserve to feel good too I love you
always you're strong enough to do
whatever you want you know who you are
I am Awana
[Music]